how effective are personality tests
one for the hiring process but also for
understanding a human being so
personality is extremely important for
understanding human being and i would
say that there's a thousand different
ways of looking at personality the only
one that i count with any with any
significance is the mbti and the mbti is
what all the leading spy agencies around
the world use as well
well that's kind of interesting to hear
oh yeah there's been criticisms of that
kind of test there have been criticisms
for a long time yeah and you think
there's value absolutely absolutely and
here's there's a few reasons why right
so first mbti makes the claim that your
core personality doesn't change
over time
and that's how it's that's how it's
calibrated and one of the big arguments
is that people say that your personality
can change over time
now what i in my experience the mbti is
exactly correct you can your core
personality does not change because your
core personality is is defined as your
personality when all resources are
removed
so essentially your emergency mode your
dire conditions that is your core
personality
we can all act a little more extroverted
we can all
you know be a little more empathetic
when we have tons of time and money and
patience
when you strip away all that time money
and patience how empathetic are you
how
how much do you like being around other
people how much do you like being alone
do you make judgments or do you do you
analyze information
that's what's so powerful about mbti is
it's talking about what people are like
when you strip away resources and then
because it's so consistent it's also
only four codes it's super easy
to be able to assess a human being
through a dialogue through a series of
conversations to be able to hone in with
high accuracy
what is there for code
four letter code there's only 16 options
and it becomes extremely valuable is it
perfectly precise and does everybody do
it the same i mean those things are the
answers to those are no but is it
operationally useful
in a short period of time that is a
resoundingly powerful yes
yeah i just i i only know i think the
first letter it's the introvert and
extroverted right uh
i i've taken the test before just like a
crude version of the test and that's the
same problem you have with iq tests yeah
there's the right
uh thorough way of doing it and then
there's like fun internet way
and uh
i do you mind sharing what your
uh
personality um my my type index yes i'm
an entp that's an extrovert intuitor
perceiver
thinker ent thinker p perceiver my wife
is an isfj
which is the polar opposite of me
e i'm extroverted she's introverted i'm
an intuiter she's a sensor uh
uh i'm a thinker she's a feeler i'm a
perceiver she's a judger is there good
science on like uh
long-term successive relationships in
terms of the dynamics of that the 16
i wonder if there's good data on this i
don't i don't think there's a lot of
good data in personalities writ large
yeah because there's not a lot of money
to be made in personality testing but i
would say that there's
that with
with experience
with a good mbti test with a good paid
test a 400 500 question test
once you understand your own code and
then you're you're taught how to assess
the code of others
with those two things kind of combined
because then you have experience in
learning
uh it's
it becomes very useful and you can have
high confidence in this in the
conclusions that you reach about
people's professions
about people's relationships with family
about people's relationships
professionally people's capabilities to
deal with stress uh how people will
perform uh when pushed outside of their
comfort zones
really really powerful useful stuff in
corporate world and in the espionage
world so in terms of compressed
representation of another human being
um
you can't do much better than those four
letters i don't believe you can do much
better in my experience i have not seen
anything better
yeah it is kind of
it's uh difficult to realize that there
is a core personality or the degree
that's true it seems to be true
it's even more difficult
to realize that there is a stable
at least the science so a stable
consistent intelligence
unfortunately
uh you know the g factor that they call
that uh if you do a barrage of iq tests
that's going to um
consistently represent that g factor and
we're all born with that we can't fix it
yeah and that defines so much of who we
are
it's sad
i don't see it as sad because it's for
me
the faster you learn it the faster you
learn what your own
sort of
natural strengths and weaknesses are
the faster you get to stop wasting time
yeah
on things that you're never going to be
good at and you get to double down on
the things that you're already naturally
skilled or interested in so there is a
there's always a silver lining to a
cloud but i know now that i will never
be a ballerina
or a ballerino i know that i'll never be
an artist i'll never be a musician i'll
never be any of those things and when i
was 18 that might have made me sad but
now at 42 i'm like well [ __ ] awesome i
can go be something else good instead of
always being bad you're not gonna be a
ballerina oh let me know because i'm not
graceful
and you you've you've you've learned
this through years of experience yeah
exactly well i don't know if there's an
mbti equivalent for the for grace of
movement i think it's called s sensor oh
yeah because a sensor is someone who's
able to interact with the world around
them through their five senses very
effectively
like if you talk to dancers dancers can
actually feel the grace in all of their
muscles they know what position their
finger is in
i don't have any idea i don't know what
position my feet are in right now i'd
have to look to make sure i actually
feel the floor right yeah i definitely
have
oh that's good to know so i don't you
know i'm not a dancer but i do have that
you're a musician man like well the
music i don't be able to plug a guitar
sure yeah that's true that there is a
physical component but i think
deeper because there's a technical
aspect to that
that's just like um
it's less about feel but i do know
jiu-jitsu you know in grappling i've
done all my life
i don't
you know there's some people who are
clumsy and they drop stuff all the time
they run into stuff
i don't i don't first of all i don't
know how that happens but to me
i just have an awareness of stuff like
if there's a spiritual orientation yeah
like
like i know that there's a small object
i have to step over and i have a good
sense of that it's so it's so
interesting yeah you're just like born
with letters my wife is brilliant and
she still walks into doors yeah
i mean she'll walk in a doorway she'll
bang her knee on the same wall that's
been there for the last 50 years it's
for some reason really hilarious so it's
good
you